[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans le 8 30 politique
france info avec myriam en kawa de la
chaîne parlementaire bonjour myriam
bonjour merci bonjour à tous deux
invités ce matin avec nous un an jour
pour jour après l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit on va évidemment parler longuement
nous sommes avec la secrétaire d'état à
la jeunesse et à l'engagement sarra el
aissi bonjour bonjour merci d'être sur
france info ce matin vous publié dans
quelques jours envie de france sept aux
édition de l'observatoire est à vos
côtés il ya matière à gabu de jallatte
bonjour à vous bonjour massés pour
l'invitation je vous en prie vous êtes
professeur d'histoire-géographie à
toulouse militante féministe est engagé
pour la défense de la laïcité on peut
commencer peut-être avec vous fathi abou
de jallatte sur cette information de la
nuit dernière l'assassinât du député
conservateur britannique david haye metz
poignardée dans sa permanence assassinat
à caractère terroriste potentiellement
islamistes que pensez vous d'une telle
d'une telle affaire
déjà
qu'on ne pourra jamais obtenir une
protection à 100 % ne pourra jamais de
mettre des policiers partout et qui a
toujours ce risque c'est devenu un aléa
en géographie des risques on parle
d'aller à voilà c'est un aléa il faut
réduire les vulnérabilités et que les
élus doivent avoir le courage puisqu'ils
sont visés en france ils ont été
violentés notamment l'année dernière ils
ont ils ont été de plus en plus la cible
de 2 de violence mais il faut avoir le
courage de rester dans la proximité et
si vous restez dans la proximité pas
forcément vous êtes plus vulnérable donc
c'est toujours très triste pour une
démocratie mais
sarah l aérés moi c'est même beaucoup
choqué parce que ya à peine quelques
quelques mois je suis moi-même député
mcg gcg l'assemblée nationale et on a
vécu des périodes avec plus ou moins de
violence chez nous nous sommes pas
arrivés à ce degré là c'est extrêmement
choquant parce que finalement quand on
s'attaque à citoyens mais encore plus à
un élu eh bien on essaye de le museler
de le faire de le faire peur et c'est
cette peur qui peut animer elle est là
encore vous là vous la connaissez ou pas
cette peur est bien sûr parfois on l'a
parfois on la voit et on se fait on se
fait violence aussi pour ne pas se
laisser embarquer par cette peur pour ne
pas la laisser gagner si cette peur
venait à gagner alors de fait il aurait
gagné et il sait qui c'est tout ce qui
nous qui essayent de terroriser de
fragmenter ou d'imposer leurs dogmes ou
leur vision et donc je pense évidemment
à sa famille à ses collègues mais à
toutes les démocraties parce que il faut
hélas je veux rejoindre madame où t'es
là il faut absolument pas à prendre faut
pas prendre de distance évidemment faut
rester au contact évidemment faut
continuer à défendre ses convictions et
c'est bien là force est bien des pays
qui sont les héritiers des lumières
alors on a exactement un an jour pour
jour 1 16 octobre 2020 16 octobre 2021
après l'assassinât effroyable de samuel
pâtit dont on garde évidemment mémoire
le vidage et le nom il ya une cérémonie
au collège du bois d'aulne sous haute
sécurité à conflans sainte honorine tout
à l'heure avec jean michel blanquer
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire ce
matin dans après à qui vous pensez en
priorité à quoi qu'est ce que vous
ressentez sara lee 1 en un an ou
finalement cet hommage s'est passé quand
même dans une sorte de mobilisation
générale
dans une sorte de mobilisation de
plusieurs âges moi j'ai hier j'étais en
loire atlantique que ce soit dans des
écoles des collèges ou des lycées le
visage de samuel patty est aujourd'hui
un symbole je pense à sa famille bien
sûr parce qu'il manque en tant que
samuel en tant que personne en tant que
fils en tant qu' en tant que frère mais
au delà de ça c'est un combattant de
cette liberté et on n'a pas baissé les
chine on n'a pas arrêté à défendre on
n'a pas arrêté de défendre le ski est le
fruit de son cours c'est à dire c'est
liberté cette liberté de conscience 7 et
berthet 7 et berthet de la presse cette
laïcité qui est malmené aujourd'hui mais
les conditions d'enseignement les
conditions de cet enseignement exemple
ont changé oui elles ont changé elles
ont changé elles continueront à changer
après ce qui a changé de verlan il n'y a
pas de baguette magique et ça faut
l'assumer faut le dire bien ce qu'est ce
qui a changé depuis un an par les
professeurs les pour les enseignants
d'abord et avant tout une volonté
politique claire et assumée jean michel
blanquer n'a jamais dévié d'un
millimètre sur le sujet la volonté
certes les actes les actes une
protection fonctionnelle systématique ça
veut dire quoi pour les gens qui nous
écoutent ça veut dire le soutien
de sa hiérarchie et par la justice des
frais de justice des enseignants qui qui
vont poser défendre dénoncer des
situations où il ya des attentats licite
et c'est aussi des formations donc allez
y c'est l'état paiera les frais de
justice bien sûr bien sûr celle là c'est
toute l'éducation nationale qui prend
qui ne met plus en question la
protection fonctionnelle donc la
protection mais c'est aussi des
formations c'est aussi des fois on
parlait gago gît dans le détail et ça
c'est le détail des vous pas allé du
soutien de l'institution protection
fonctionner c'est une chose la sécurité
mais il ya aussi du soutien de la
hiérarchie fatiha gac budget l'at on a
entendu énormément d'enseignants nous
dire au fond samuel pâtit ça aurait pu
être moi est-ce que déjà le traumatisme
est toujours là la blessure est toujours
ouverte et est ce que vous vous avez vu
sur le terrain des changements très
clair de soutien d'institutions un an
après
je pense vraiment comme le disait la
secrétaire d'état qu'avec le ministre
blanc caire il ya quelque chose quand
même qui a changé dans en termes de
ventes et politique je suis pas sûr que
ce soit déclinée localement sur le
terrain parce que l'autocensure elle
peut être celle des profs parce qu'ils
ont peur d'être considérés comme étant
en difficulté professionnelle donc il ya
des gens qui cache il ya aussi le chef
d'établissement qui des fois vouloir
gérer en interne pour ne pas porter
préjudice à l'attractivité de
l'établissement
portante voilà le pas de vagues et puis
au niveau du rectorat maintenant c'est
vrai qu'il ya des choses il ya les
équipes valeurs de la république il ya
des équipes de sécurité qu'on peut sur
le climat scolaire que l'on peut faire
intervenir il ya même une plateforme où
on peut signaler les enseignants peuvent
signaler des atteintes à la laïcité sans
passer par l'autorité hiérarchique parce
que c'était là aussi qu'il y avait un
espèce de goulots d'étranglement qui
entraînait cette rétention de
l'information moi je pense à ça mieux le
pâtis je pense déjà au père au fils
qu'il était
à sa famille et je dirais pas que ça
aurait pu être chaque prof heureusement
heureusement il ya 1 800 mille
enseignants à millions de personnes qui
travaillent dans l'éducation nationale
et heureusement on a des relations très
proches avec les enfants mais ce qui est
très douloureux c'est sa solitude parce
qu'il a été seul voilà il a été seul et
s'il n'avait pas été victime de cette de
cette cet assassinat odieux je pense
qu'il aurait été sanctionné est ce que
les profs en moins seule aujourd'hui est
ce que les profs sont moins seul
aujourd'hui
les profs font état sur les réseaux
sociaux de maintenant on peut
communiquer sur ça mais beaucoup reste
avec des pseudos ou sous l'anonymat
parce que ils ont cette pression et pas
simplement
de la direction la pression elle peut
aussi se faire par les pairs c'est à
dire par les syndicalistes ou par les
collègues qui vous dira il faut le
comprendre l'année dernière à toulouse
au même moment que de que l'assassinât
de samuel pâtit j'ai une collègue d'arts
plastiques dans un bon collège qui a été
qui a eu affaire à un élève qui a fait
l'apologie de terrorisme qui a défendu
les frères kwasi est en fait cet élève
de quatrième depuis la 6e il contestait
son enseignement lui disant qu'elle
n'avait pas le droit de montrer des
statuts nu des statues grecques nu et
rien ne s'était passé rien ne s'était
passé le chef d'établissement dizaine
n'en faut pas parce que c'est des gamins
qui sont là dans le cadre du programme
mixité ça va porter préjudice et ce qui
est terrible c'est qu'il a fallu passer
par la justice est là aussi a eu un
changement c'est à dire qu'avant quand
on portait plainte les policiers dizaine
de mains courantes
il n'en était pas maintenant il ya un
vrai et un vrai changement au niveau du
système judiciaire et c'est le procureur
qui a obligé en faite le le chef
d'établissement a convoqué un conseil de
discipline et mais le gamin a eu une
exclusion avec sursis et il a été
dispensé de cours d'arts plastiques et
ça voilà je voudrais dire ce n'est pas
une solution ce n'est pas entendable
pareil les appels comment se fait-il que
les appels liés au temps d'appel après
les conseils de discipline qui casse les
décisions des conseils de discipline
bien on va poursuivre cette discussion
dans un instant juste après le fil info
puisqu'il est 20h40 laurence mérite pour
l'essentiel
[Musique]
98 incidents recensés hier dans les
établissements scolaires lors de
l'hommage à samuel pâtit annonces du
ministre de l'éducation nationale ce
matin sur france 2 jean michel blanquer
a évoqué des cas d'élèves menaçant ou
qui disent n'importe quoi vendredi des
millions d'élèves vont commémorer
l'assassinât du professeur d'histoire
géo qui avait montré à sa classe des
caricatures de mahomet cet après midi la
famille de samuel patty est reçu à
l'elysée après des milliers de réactions
sur twitter le hashtag mitu théâtre dans
la rue ce matin le collectif contre les
violences sexuelles dans le milieu du
théâtre donne rendez-vous à 11 heures
devant le palais royal à paris dans une
tribune publiée dans le journal
libération ils demandent le lancement
d'une enquête pour une prise de
conscience du phénomène dans le secteur
les signataires appellent aussi à
protéger les étudiants des écoles d'art
dramatique le groupe etat islamique
revendique l'attentât suicide d'hier en
afghanistan une explosion a fait au
moins 41 morts dans une mosquée chiite
de kandahar capitale provinciale du sud
et berceau des talibans au pouvoir le
coc vide l'instabilité politique les
conflits où le réchauffement climatique
compliquer l'accès à la nourriture selon
un dernier rapport 800 millions
d'habitants souffrent de faim dans le
monde ces 25 % de plus qu il y a deux
ans grâce à un but et une passe décisive
de killian bape et le psg s'impose
difficilement 2 en face à angers la
suite de la 10e journée de ligue 1
aujourd'hui à 17 heures clermont lille à
21h lyon monaco
franceinfo lui 30 france info nous
évoquons ce matin à l'hommage à samuel
pâtit un an après cet assassinat qui
pose toujours énormément de questions
nous sommes avec deux invités sahara est
là éric et secrétaire d'état à la
jeunesse et à l'engagement et fatiha
gagbo jannat militante et enseignante
myriam on kawara oui je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur ces phénomènes
d'autocensure dans le corps enseignant
il ya des sondages qui montrent que pour
la fondation jean jaurès sondage ifop un
enseignant sur deux se serait auto
censuré au moins une fois 25% plusieurs
fois écoutez ce ce professeur du lycée
simone weil à boulogne il expliquait
comment il a dû préparer cet hommage et
parler de laïcité vin ne va pas
forcément de soi pour lui on réfléchit
aux termes qu'on va utiliser face à des
élèves comment ils vont le percevoir
comment ils vont recevoir ces mots et je
ne m'interdis pas de l'aborder mais
évidemment j'y réfléchis et certainement
plus qu'avant ça l aérés on sent bien
qu'il faut de la formation il ce concept
de laïcité il n'est pas forcément
maîtriser facile pour tout le monde
elle manque aujourd'hui cette formation
qu'est ce qui va se déployer
concrètement sur le terrain manque oui
elle a manqué parce que beaucoup pendant
trop longtemps la laïcité a été un pli
site aujourd'hui notre volonté la
volonté du ministre évidemment c'est
qu'elle soit explicite c'est qu'elles
soient enseignées c'est qu'elles soient
maîtrisés pour que les enseignants ne
soit pas pris en étau dans ou dans
l'incapacité d'expliquer forme des
formateurs sur le moment on entend ça va
essaimer sur le terrain dans les états
formant un keylogger on paie
actuellement depuis 2000 réalité depuis
2010 est il ya un conseil des sages de
laïcité il y a le guide de l'école
républicaine qui pose ses valeurs mais
la laïcité elle se vit elle se vit c'est
à dire qu'elle se pratique au quotidien
dire que ces enseignants aujourd'hui ils
ont évidemment les outils pédagogiques
pour expliquer c'est quoi la laïcité ne
pas laisser dire également que c'est une
loi qui contraint qui réduit les
libertés bien au contraire les protège
et je crois que pour embarquer cette
jeunesse qui aujourd'hui pour une partie
d'entre elles et bien ne la comprends
pas bien il faut lui faire vivre pour
qu'elle voit à quel point cette laïcité
est nécessaire pour notre vivre ensemble
où je vais vous parler de la jeunesse je
voudrais juste vous ramener à poitiers
vous voyez très bien de quoi je veux
parler vous vous êtes rendus dans une
sorte de forum de jeunes organisé par
une association à poitiers c'était
quelques semaines seulement après
l'assassinât de samuel potier la
dialogue de sourds total sa a été filmée
par france 3 régions
clairement ces jeunes vous disait madame
la ministre nous on ne veut plus la loi
2004 sur la laïcité et de l'interdiction
des signes religieux on veut pouvoir
porter le voile au lycée ça vous a
marqué qu est ce que vous avez retenu de
ce face à face bien sûr que ça m'a
marqué et en réalité c'était au
lendemain même de l'hommage à la
sorbonne se dire que la veille on était
avec ses parents il y avait ce cercueil
qui traversait la sorbonne le lendemain
même mais cette jeunesse en réalité ce
qui m'a le plus marqué c'est que les
personnes qu'il encadrait les adultes
qui doivent être ses figures d'autorité
leurs familles les associations qui les
accompagnent
n'avait pas transmises à quel point la
laïcité et bien c'est un acte de liberté
c'est une loi de liberté ni lésions
parents d'élèves également yanks bien
sûr pour moi il y a une une question de
l'ensemble des maillons qui transmettent
la l'autorité qui pose l'apprentissage
que ce soit les enseignants et il faut
les accompagner les doter parce que
pendant plus de dix ans on a considéré
que c'était un acquis la laïcité sauf
que quand on ne sait plus la définir
alors on la perd et aujourd'hui c'est un
combat un combat pour la laïcité pour
que chacun se ressaisissent et ça
commence dès le plus jeune âge fatiha
gags gujarat vous qui est enseignante je
vous voulez vous entendre sur ce que
nous disait tout à l'heure ce professeur
du lycée simone weil à boulogne lisait
il faut maintenant réfléchir aux termes
et à la présentation de tel ou tel sujet
est-ce que ça c'est pas commun à tous
les sujets et tous les enseignements
mais c'est exactement ce que j'étais en
train de me dire quand on dit que c'est
un problème de formation moi j'ai du mal
à accepter ça parce que c'est comme si
en fait ça mais elle pâtit bassi s'ils
étaient mieux pris ça lui serait pas
arrivé c'est pas un problème de
formation surtout pas pour les profs
d'histoire-géo par contre effectivement
il ya beaucoup d'enseignants qui restent
dans leur tour d'ivoire disciplinaires
et les profs de maths nous disait mais
moi je peux pas parler de la laïcité qui
connais rien je veux pas voilà alors
qu'en fait les valeurs de la république
c'est dans toutes les disciplines
la science l'égalité filles garçons
c'est dans toutes les disciplines mais
aussi blanc qu'il faudra en parler
davantage
vers salle comme alors bien sûr nous
quand on est enseignant on n'est pas
simplement dans l' expertise
disciplinaire on doit être efficace dans
notre façon de nous exprimer quand on
parle d'auto censure ça veut pas dire
ça veut pas dire qu'on fait pas qu'on
vérifie chaque terme qu'on utilise je
pense que certains enseignants et vite
carrément certains sujets à l'école
précis et lesquelles par exemple quand
on doit faire la la décolonisation au
programme de troisième on a le choix on
peut faire l'inde ou l'algérie voilà je
pense que beaucoup d'enseignants par
facilité fonds l'inde parce que c'est
très loin qu'il pense qu'il aura pas de
tensions on va aller vite sur la
chaussée des choses comme ça et vous
vous avez eu des élèves déjà qu'ils ont
contesté directement des éléments de
programmes qui vont dire madame ça ne se
dit pas ça ne se fait pas ou qui dénonce
des blagues des blasphèmes par exemple
ça se produit qui est concrètement
qu'est ce qu'on entend dans les classes
écoutez il faut qu'on accepte ça bien
sûr que ça se produit quand on défend la
liberté d'expression on défend aussi
celle de ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec nous donc on fournit des armes on
forme des citoyens on forme pas des
petits robots des clones moi tout ce que
je veux mon travail c'est qu'il soit
capable de me dire à moi je trouve que
la laïcité c'est exagéré ou je suis
content la loi de 2004 mais avec des
arguments que ce soit pas simplement ce
qu'ils ont entendu chez eux parce que
c'est ça les gamins ils sont dans un
conflit de loyauté entre les parents
leurs amis et l'école justement
l'impression que la laïcité c'est que
l'école et que ça ils sont obligés de
trahir leurs parents qui va choisir
l'école contre les parents et moi je dis
que c'est là où elle bat le bât blesse
c'est qu'on s'adresse pas assez aux
parents les gamins ne font que répéter
16 go leurs rapports des enseignants aux
familles a vraiment évolué très
fortement au fil des années ça dépend
des situations des établissements si
vous êtes dans un établissement ultra
ghettoïser avait 99 % d'élèves musulmans
bien sûr que c'est très compliqué tout
comme j'ai vu que dans un collège
bellefontaine à la cantine à toulouse il
y avait de la nourriture halal voilà il
y avait le panneau alors que c'est
formellement interdit parce que quand
vous avez 4 1 19% ou même 100% c'est
plus compliqué que si vous êtes dans un
bahut du centre ville on essaye de faire
de grands efforts par rapport à la
famille on parle même ma tante collège
hospitalier on essaie de les faire venir
mais il ya toujours ce problème de
confiance et c
c'est la difficulté c'est vraiment quand
les enseignants sont contestés à cause
de ce qu'ils sont c'est à dire que moi
les élèves vont moins m'accuser de
racisme
voilà c'est pas qu'ils pensent qu'on est
raciste c'est que c'est de bonne guerre
qu'ils essayent de tester je dirais même
c'est la lutte des classes dans les deux
sens du terme ils essayent de tester si
l'enseignant a l'impression qu'il n'est
pas soutenue par sa direction j'avais il
ya deux ans il y avait des cours sur la
prévention des maladies sexuellement
transmissibles et deux élèves me dise
non non c'est le ramadan on peut pas
parler de sexe non non non et le
principal passé par là j'ai dit monsieur
le principal elle refuse d'assister à ce
cours obligatoires et leur dit soyez pas
ridicule vous y allez vous taisez asie
sont allés s'est par contre elles sont à
écouter faux-pas of a oui je voudrais
pas vous enfoncez 6 à 7 obséquiosité qui
consiste à prendre les devants à avoir
tellement peur qu'on est justement dans
cette démarche de dire ah on va
s'arranger mais là je suis désolé là ils
vont se dire on est roue libre on va
montrer notre acte de foi on va montrer
qu'on est des bons musulmans à s'il ya
de la fermeté la fermeté paye et la
fermeté profite aux enfants ont fait une
petite pause dans cette discussion pour
le fil info avec laurence mairie dit les
20h50
emmanuel macron va devenir le premier
président français à commémorer le
massacre du 17 octobre il se rendra cet
après midi au pont de bezons dans la
commune de colombes où soixante ans plus
tôt des milliers de manifestants
algériens ont été frappés certains jetés
dans la seine bilan officiel trois morts
mais plus de 200 pour les historiens le
chef de l'état observera une minute de
silence avant un échange avec les
familles des victimes
aucun discours du président n'est prévu
l'enquète sur l'assassinât d'un député
britannique confiée aux services
antiterroristes david et metz a été
poignardé à plusieurs reprises hier lors
d'une permanence parlementaire alliantie
à londres un acte qualifié d'attentât
potentiellement islamique par la police
un homme de 25 ans a été arrêtée moderna
ok pour une première et une deuxième
dose mais pas pour une troisième la
haute autorité de santé attend l'avis de
l'agencé européenne du médicament sur
des risques de péricardite et de
myocardite seul le vaccin files heures
et pour l'instant autorisée en france
pour une troisième dose grâce aux
vaccins les restrictions contre locaux
vides s'assouplissent après plus d'un an
de fermeture les frontières américaines
vont rouvrir dans trois semaines le 8
novembre pour entrer aux états unis il
faudrait être doublement vacciner avec
pfizer moderna ou encore astrazeneca lui
ou elle pourra se payer un aller retour
à new york les yeux fermés un chanceux
est reparti avec une cagnotte de 220
millions d'euros lors du tirage de
l'euromillion hier soir c'est le plus
gros gain remporté dans l'histoire de la
loterie européenne depuis 2004
france info deux invités ce matin dans
le micro de france info nous sommes avec
sarah el hariri et fatiha à gags gujarat
série tout à l'heure fatiha boudjellal
est expliqué que le chef d'établissement
doit être ferme que l'autorité doit être
présente et qu'il faut aller dans ce
cours de svt c'est obligatoire ça ne
vous choque pas que les hommages à
samuel patick se sont tenues dans les
collèges et les lycées de france hier
n'est pas été obligatoire c'est pas
désolant au fond qu'on dise au fond
c'est mieux comme ça non ils ont été
obligatoire dans le sens où il ils
doivent avoir lieu par contre non c'est
leur organisation est en réalité les
chiffres sont en train d'être contre
ceux qui ne voulaient rien faire pouvait
le faire mais tout le monde s'est engagé
mais pourquoi parce que samuel pâtit
c'est ce symbole même de les des équipes
pédagogiques
c'est ces enseignants c'est ces
infirmières c'est c'est c'est tous et
toutes les équipes en fait qui
permettent la transmission mais c'est
pas une famille déjà de comment dire de
renoncement de ne pas de vagues de dire
plutôt chacun fait comme il veut si on
ne veut rien faire bien sûr dans le
respect des élèves mais si on ne veut
rien faire et bien c'est possible je
vous assure que non personne n'a rien
fait du tout parce que par contre il ya
des adaptations c'est à dire que quand
on est petit il ya eu des minutes de
silence dans moi j'ai participé à un
cours d'histoire géo en quatrième il ya
eu des des champs de la marseillaise
l'adaptation delà de la forme que ça
pouvait prendre oui il y a eu cette
intelligence mais pourquoi parce que cet
hommage il a été plein d'émotion partout
mais le pas de vague pour le coup il est
terminé et c'est pour ça que le ministre
jean michel blanquer a donné les
chiffres à l'instant à l'instant c'est
au moment où les arts en fonction de les
remonter il n'y a plus on ne souhaite
pas on ne veut pas mettre sous le tapis
quoi que jamais la chaîne est très
complexe à expliquer tout à l'heure
fathi abou djahl à te disais ça bloque à
plusieurs niveaux mais j'ai envie de
vous dire il peut pas changer du jour au
lendemain alors c'est pas parce que
c'est un jeu c'est pas parce que c'est
compliqué où c'est difficile que on ne
le fait pas ou ne souhaitent pas le fait
l'intention bien sûr mais les actes
aujourd'hui en train d'être transformée
regarder comment ça se passe quand on
saisit son autorité quand on a le
soutien de son recteur quand vous avez
un ministre qui ne souhaite pas qu'on
mette sous le tapis laser et el fathi
abou djahl hans impression tout a changé
écoutez je sahara et je vous assure il
ya deux choses qui ont changé la
première c'est que non la laïcité on ne
conjugue pas avec nom ne laisse pas on
ne ferme pas les yeux on donne les
chiffres on l'est on les engage et on
engage à lézignan par contre est-ce que
tu m'intéresse ce sont les actes et
cette fameuse chaîne que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure est-ce que là ça bouge
vraiment
ça dépendra beaucoup de la personnalité
du chef d'établissement bien évidemment
et il y à un principe voilà
l'éducabilité il ya des gens c'est aussi
des chefs d'établissements et
enseignants qui pense sincèrement qu'il
faut il ne faut pas stigmatiser l'enfant
les protéger l'établissement scolaire
protéger l'établissement mais aussi
voilà ça de ne pas mettre en défaut
l'enfant qui va après subir des
procédures des sanctions disciplinaires
donc c'est dans ce sens-là positif mais
le problème c'est que les enfants ont
besoin de la limite tout ce qu'ils vont
tout ce qu'il risque c'est un rappel à
la loi et en général on convoque leur
part ans les enfants dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure de 4e il a été
alors lui il a été mis en garde à vue
parce que quand même c'était de
l'apologie de terrorisme en quatrième et
il ya eu un rappel à la loi des parents
fait par le procureur ça c'est beaucoup
plus efficace que d'être dispensé de
cours d'arts plastiques et voila
j'aimerais bien est une mesure très
simple à prendre c'est de dire un enfant
de retourne jamais dans l'établissement
même quand le rectorat casse la décision
d'exclusion du conseil de discipline ça
ce serait plutôt est ce qu'on n'a pas
fait preuve d'un immense angélisme en
fait sur ce sujet et il faut un drame
atroce pour en sortir tout le monde a
tourné les yeux et c'est le fruit de
dizaines d'années en réalité de petites
compromissions parce que peuvent pas de
vagues parce que climat de
l'établissement parce que des
associations qui ont pas spécialement
envie d'aller parler d'un sujet qui ne
savent pas traiter et et aussi parce que
la laïcité n'était pas comprise ou de
moins en moins comprise et que donc
c'est conduisait longer de la règlement
je crois et de la facilité alors même
qu' il y a des mots clés et le combat
aujourd'hui il est dorée expliqué il est
de reposer elle est restée comme un
esprit dans ce qui s'est passé avant les
quelques semaines qui ont précédé
l'assassinât de sa mère pattie beaucoup
d' enquête de contre enquête commence à
montrer que le chef d'établissement
notamment n'a pas vérifié tout de suite
que l'élève a menti qu'elle n'était pas
présente en classe
même le maire de conflans reconnaît une
forme de culpabilité
ils avaient été saisis n'a pas pris les
mesures de protection il ya eu une
chaîne
comment dire de l'acheter il ya précédé
il ya une chaîne et la lumière est en
train d'être faites sur les faits étape
par étape et aujourd'hui il ya deux
énormément comme plus de clarté sur
l'enchaînement des actions par contre
depuis qu'est ce qui s'est passé cette
chaîne on l'a cassé avec une loi la loi
qui renforce les principes de la
république pour engager la
responsabilité on attend plus est
d'ailleurs maintenant chaque fois qu'il
y à une situation d'urgence il ya
automatiquement la saisine des des
référents laïcité sa raillerie et ça
c'est une nouveauté beaucoup plus de
seconde ou dit plus de clarté mais fathi
abou djahl à deux vous n'avez pas l'air
d'accord
ah non mais je sais je suis persuadé de
la sincérité de la secrétaire d'état
sauf que les trackers de l'inspection
générale de l'éducation nationale voilà
24 pages même pas le nom de samuel pâtit
sur les 24 pages en fait il ya trois
quatre plages blanches avec le sommaire
qu'en fait il ya 19 pages sur ces
événements là est il ce rapport servait
à absoudre est là heureusement il ya la
justice qui enquête pour essayer de
montrer les autres
responsabilités donc c'est pas du
gouvernement cercle c'est ça c'est ce
que vous voulez dire je pense que il ya
la volonté politique mais sur la chaîne
d'inertie d'aidé de certains hauts
fonctionnaires ou de l'inspection voilà
il a faux là moi je crois que là il ya
un enjeu sera le 6 mai tout c'est à dire
que oui il faut une volonté politique
oui il faut des enseignants qui n'ait
pas peur qu'ils aient les outils
pédagogiques et c'est ce que nous
faisons oui il faut des rectorats qui
tiennent la même ligne mais le jeune
artistique évidemment que la juge fermés
soit ferme évidemment les eaux venant
d'annoncer sais c'est la force d'un état
de droit comme le nôtre et c'est là où
il ne faut pas absolument pas de
compromission ou de conjugaison ou même
d'atténuation des situations merci
beaucoup à tout les deux séries et
fatiha galles gujarat invité du 8 30
france info ce matin
[Musique]